what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder i'm your host
warren thompson and today we have some
really really exciting marvel cinematic
universe news because today we have our
very first look at black panther wakanda
forever some official promo art has been
revealed giving us our first look at
namor the main villain of wakanda
forever or is he going to be the main
villain because we also have some promos
for a different villain we've been led
to believe that namor is going to be the
main antagonist of wakanda forever
however i think we may have sort of a
batman vs superman type of situation
here if you have been following the
channel you know that i believe that yes
they're going to kind of go at war with
each other but then there's going to be
a different villain that they have to
unite together to fight kind of giving a
little bit of a truce between atlantis
and wakanda who have a history of being
at war with another and to top it all
off we also have our first look at riri
williams's iron heart and of course
we'll be looking at that in this video
as well so let's break down these new
promotional photos for black panther
wakanda forever and if you love marvel
and want to stay in the know be sure to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest news now the promo art that we're
going to be showing today has been
released by mcu underscore facility
we'll show them on the youtube channel
here but you can also find them on my
twitter and instagram and the first one
we'll start off with is of shuri and
okoye now nothing is really too new with
these women in this photo in fact okoye
looks pretty much exactly the same
looking like a true dora milaje sure he
is wearing a little bit different
clothing than we normally see her in and
she has a different hairstyle but
besides that mostly everything is pretty
much the same here however we may be
looking at the new black panther some
rumors have indicated since chadwick
boseman is no longer with us sadly and
since marvel studios has announced that
they are not going to be recasting
t'challa that shuri while it might be
temporary might be the next black
panther this is a pretty big question
that everybody has right now who is
going to be the new black panther there
are people like shuri who could take on
the mantle or imbaku or they could
simply bring somebody new in we'll have
to wait and see on that but in the
meantime we do have our very first look
at riri williams in her iron heart suit
as you see here she is in her full suit
and we also have some other promo art
that was released for iron heart and we
can see the ark reactor and her arc
reactor specifically is shaped like a
heart now for those of you who are not
aware it is confirmed that riri williams
is going to be in black panther 2
wakanda forever she is going to be
playing somewhat of a significant role
although it may be somewhat brief but we
do know that these events are going to
tie in directly with the events of her
own series that she is getting the iron
heart series and honestly this looks
really really good and if we take a look
at her helmet it kind of looks like it
shattered a bit however this could be
intentional perhaps her helmet kind of
comes apart like that i'd be really
shocked if they were showing us in this
promo image her getting attacked and
it's shattering i'm sure they're going
to include some new technology to her
iron heart suit and since marvel does
have a tendency to change comic book
origins she might even be from wakanda
so there is a possibility that this
could have some wakandan technology in
it it actually might be made of
vibranium we don't know at this point
but it is going to be really cool to see
her in wakanda forever and i'm really
looking forward to the iron heart show
and of course what everybody is really
excited about we have our very first
look at namor and if you're not aware
yet tinnock huerta is going to be
playing namor in black panther wakanda
forever and this is him now right away
you may notice that this has kind of
given up mayan vibes this has been
rumored and reported on for a while now
that in black panther wakanda forever
the atlanteans are also kind of going to
be like ancient mayans which makes
perfect sense we are talking about
ancient civilizations here and i'm
really excited to see how they're going
to do the story of atlantis how it sunk
underwater we thought that we might have
gotten this story in the eternals since
they covered such a broad range of time
in the eternals but unfortunately it did
not happen however much like in the very
first black panther film how they sort
of briefly went over the history of
wakanda hopefully that will happen in
black panther 2 and that would just make
sense for them to go over the history
and origin of atlantis if they're going
to be at war with atlantis you kind of
got to give us some of that backstory
otherwise the general population is just
going to be sitting there watching going
okay who are these people what's their
deal so i would expect to see their
origin story and it looks like they are
sticking true to what namor sort of
looks like in the comics because the
atlanteans are blue their skin is blue
but namor skin is not that is because
namor is only half atlantean he's half
atlantean and half human slash mutant
now namor is known to be a mutant and i
know that this may excite people but i'm
not holding my breath for him to be a
mutant in the mcu and even if he is i
don't think they're really going to talk
about it we've had a lot of instances so
far where we thought that the mutants
were going to get introduced or they
were going to hint at it in some way
shape or form but sadly we have not
gotten anything about the mutants or
x-men in the mcu yet the only thing that
we've got is doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness and spoiler alert
professor xavier's in it who of course
is one of the most popular mutants in
x-men of all time but he was sadly in
another universe however when it comes
to black panther wakanda forever it
could be hinted at a little bit more but
i do think it's going to be kind of
vague i think they'll talk about how he
has certain powers some powers that
typical atlanteans don't have and
perhaps those powers came from his other
half but i don't think they'll straight
up come out and say oh his other half
yeah he's actually part mutant as well
but i've said this before after doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
came out marvel can only go so long
without addressing mutants and the
fantastic four in our current mcu doctor
strange has now come in contact with
both of these groups it would make sense
for him to go seek them out in his own
universe it really doesn't make sense
for him not to seek out these really
powerful really intelligent people or at
least look and see if there's another
illuminati formed in the earth 616
universe and kevin feige and a lot of
insiders have said that some big
announcements are coming pretty soon at
sdcc and at d23 could mutants be
announced to be coming to the mcu soon
who knows but if they are it would
definitely make sense for them to kind
of explore the fact that neymar the
submariner is part mutant so like i said
in the beginning the atlanteans and the
wakandans have had beef with each other
for a pretty long time and that'll
probably take up a good chunk of the
story of black panther wakanda forever
but like i said i don't think namor is
going to be the villain here well
sometimes he is when he's taken over by
the phoenix force but most of the time
he's not so i've always assumed that by
the end of wakanda forever he wouldn't
be left as a villain and based off of
some art that we have today it looks
like that is probably true as we have
some art of atuma atuma is a namor
villain a villain of atlantis now
originally atuma was born to a barbaric
atlantean tribe this tribe would
eventually be banished from atlantis now
eventually years down the road atuma
would go on to become the ruler of this
tribe and he told them that he vowed to
conquer atlantis and dethrone namor and
i definitely think that atuma could be
the main villain here yes neymar isn't
exactly a hero sometimes but he's more
of an anti-hero rather than a villain so
i'm thinking that wakanda and atlantis
are going to have to come together to
fight atuma because in the mcu atuma
probably doesn't just want atlantis he
probably wants some vibranium too and
perhaps if he gets his hands on some
type of atlantean technology he could
easily take over wakanda that could be a
driving force to make the wakandans and
the atlanteans fight together so our
very first look at black panther 2
wakanda forever via these promo images
let me know what you thought about them
in the comments down below i think
they're actually pretty awesome and i'm
really really excited to see what
direction black panther to wakanda
forever goes in but hit me with your
thoughts and your theories in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest news and
don't forget to check me out on
instagram and twitter typically i post
promotional images and stuff like this
before i post videos about them as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof